[موسيقى]
بعدما كان امبراطور العملات المشفره
وعبقري الاسواق الماليه الجديده بين ليله
وضحاها تحطم كل هذا على شواطئ البهاماس
سامو البنك من العمر 30 عاما اصبح منبوزا
بعد ما واجهت شركته ازمه السيوله وتقدمت
بطلب لاعلان الافلاس ما يعني منعو حصول
مالا يقل عن مليون شخص من المذيعين على
اموالهم
السقوط المدوي من النعمه الى الافلاس اذهل
المستثمرين وعشاق العملات المشفره الذين
اشد ذات مره بالامريكي باعتباره المنقذه
لهذه الصناعه
ما الذي حصل حقيقه ليدفع بالرئيس التنفيذي
السابق لشركه اف تي اكس للعملات المشفره
المنهار ان يتوجه للعالم عبر تويتر ليقول
اعتذر لانني اخطر
في الثاني من نوفمبر الماضي استشهد ما
قالوا استقصائي بوثيقه ماليه مسربه اثر
التساؤلات حول التعاملات اف تي اكس
والمخاطر العاليه التي تتخذها مع هزا اسس
النظام البيئي باكمله
وتراجعت اسعار العملات الرقميه جميعها حيث
دفع المستثمرون للخروج من المراكز
المحفوفه بالمخاطر ونتيجه لذلك وفي حاله
من الذعر زرع المذيعون لسحب اموالهم من
العديد من منصه التشفير مما اجبر المقردين
على وقف عمليات السحب
[موسيقى]
الفارس الابيض لقطاع العملات المشفره
انتهى به الامر معتقلا صناعه العملات
المشفره على حافه الهاويه في انتظار سقوط
قطاع الدومينو التاليه
[موسيقى]
انخفضت قيمه المزيد من العملات
حوالي 26 مليون دولار في ذروتها في وقت
سابقا هذا العام ولكنه اليوم موقوفا
بانتظار محاكمه وصفت بالتاريخيه في
الاوساط الامريكيه السياسيه والماليه على
حد سواء
[موسيقى]